People keep telling me they can't land
AI clients because they don't have a
YouTube channel since I got my first
clients through content. But you don't
actually need content at all. If I lost
my YouTube channel tomorrow and I had to
start from zero, there are three simple
ways that I'd get clients fast. And I
hardly see anyone talking about the
third method. So, in this video, I'll
show you real proof that you can land
clients without a YouTube channel and
the exact three steps you can follow to
sign your first few clients this month.
So, let's get into it. So, just to start
off, I'm not going to pretend that
YouTube or content doesn't help. It
absolutely does because when someone
watches a ton of your videos before
reaching out, they already have trust
and they've heard your voice. They see
how you think and by the time they book
that call, they're basically sold. And
that's the power of content. But what
most people don't realize, the agency
that I founded and exited, True Verizon,
scaled past 100K a month. And even
though the majority of our leads were
coming from YouTube, that's not where
our best clients were coming from. The
clients we ended up actually working
with, the ones who paid well, stuck
around, and were a dream to work with,
came from two things: referrals and
partnerships. So, we'd make one client
happy, and then they'd tell their
network. or we'd partner with tools or
other businesses that already had demand
that they couldn't service themselves.
And that's where the real growth came
from. So, yes, content is one path and
it's a really great way to build
momentum. But it's not the only path.
And I get it because I know a lot of you
guys don't want to start a YouTube
channel or don't want to be consistently
posting on LinkedIn every day. You don't
want to be on camera. You don't want to
wait 12 months to see results. And
that's totally fair. So, we're going to
talk about three ways that you can land
clients without posting a single piece
of content. Starting with number one,
which is cold outreach. Now, before I
get into this, I need to be real with
you. Cold outreach is brutal when you
have zero proof. The first thing that
any prospect is going to ask you is,
"Who have you done this for?" And if
your answer is nobody, you're fighting
uphill the entire conversation. So
before you go off and send a bunch of
cold messages, go get some proof. Even
if it's small, even if it's free, even
if it's for your cousin's salon, the
project doesn't need to match what you
eventually want to sell. All that
matters is that you can say, "Yeah, I
have done this before. I've helped X
business get Y result." That alone
separates you from everyone who's purely
theoretical. So there are four
components to cold outreach: platforms,
finding leads, reaching out, and then
volume. So let's start with platforms.
For B2B, here's where you should be
looking. LinkedIn, Facebook groups,
email, school communities, YouTube
channels, Instagram, Reddit. Cold email
has an average response rate of 1 to 5%,
but personalized emails see up to 17%
higher rates. LinkedIn inmail DMs have a
10 to 25% response rate compared to
email, which is much lower, but the
LinkedIn DMs require more time per
message. So, I wanted to just throw
those stats at you, but pick one or two
to start. Don't try to do outreach on
all of those platforms. You're going to
spread yourself too thin because they
all have different methods of what works
best. So once you've picked your
platform, here's where to actually find
people worth reaching out to.
Communities in your niche, followers of
relevant pages or creators, business
owners already complaining about wasting
time or making mistakes, job boards and
comment sections, because if someone's
hiring for a role, you could automate.
That's a signal. You could also look at
local businesses in your area. Pro tip
though, before you jump into something
like Apollo or LinkedIn Sales Navigator
to find a lead list, spend 10 minutes
asking CatchBT or Perplexity where
industry specific directories exist. So
like architects have the American
Institute of Architects, coaches have
coaching directories. Every industry
probably has something and these
databases have already been filtered for
you. Now when it comes to reaching out,
keep it simple. Focus on of course the
problem, the outcome, not the actual
tech solution. Nobody really cares if
you built an 18 node automation with
Naden and Slack and Notion MCP. They
care about the results, which is, you
know, more leads, less manual work,
fewer errors, faster turnaround. Short
value focused messages work better than
long pitches. Your goal is not to close
them in one message. That's just not
realistic. Your goal is to get them
curious, to start a conversation, get
them wanting more. That's why the
subject line is so important, because if
they're not curious at all, they're not
going to click to open the email. Now,
here's something, and I know it sounds a
little bit counterintuitive, but just be
completely honest about where you're at.
That's my approach at least. So, saying
something like, "Yeah, I'm just getting
started. I'm trying to start up a
business." And that doesn't undercut
you. It actually creates like a pattern
interrupt and it builds trust because
the prospect thinks, "Okay, this is
actually a real human." Instead of,
"Wow, great." You know, another faces
pitch of someone trying to sell me. And
of course, because you're unknown and
unproven, you want to remove all the
risk from your offer. So, no payment
until results, no contract. The only
thing that you ask for is permission to
use them as a case study if the solution
works. You're not asking them to trust
you and give you a ton of money. You're
making it a no-brainer for them to say
yes. And then one more thing, asking a
stranger for 30 minutes on their
calendar is a big ask. People are busy.
People don't want to hop on calls with
random people just to be sold. So,
instead, get them curious. Again, ask
them if you can send them a 2-minute
Loom video explaining the offer. And
then you can record a quick video
walking through how you'd help their
specific business and let them do the
heavy lifting before they ever get on a
call with you. All right, the numbers
game. So, in the wise words of Alex
Herozi, someone I've actually had the
pleasure of meeting multiple times,
volume negates luck. So, if you want to
guarantee clients, you just need to
increase the volume. At the very least,
you should be sending 100 messages a
day. I know that sounds like a lot, but
understand this. A small percentage of
replies is actually a really good
metric. So, we talked about the 1 to 5%
average with cold email. If you're doing
anything above 5%, you're crushing it.
Which means if you send 100 emails and
you only get five people to respond, not
book in a call or pay you, just respond,
that's actually really good. But you do
need to track everything. Your reply
rate, your positive responses, your
meetings booked, your deals closed. Each
metric tells you what area you need to
improve. And you don't just track the
wins, you also have to track all of the
negative responses because that tells
you what not to do. So when you get
positive replies, you write down the
company size, the industry, the job
title, anything else that's relevant.
And then you can start to build your
future lead lists around those patterns.
And this is how you actually
systematically improve instead of just
guessing. Now, here are the two things
that most people do get wrong with cold
outreach. The first one is maybe just
don't build before you sell. If you're
spending weeks perfecting an automation
before you've talked to a single
customer, you don't have a business, you
just have a hobby. You need to use cold
outreach as market research. Create an
offer around something that you could
build that you know it's feasible and
then send messages about it. See if
anyone bites. If they do, and you see
market validation, then go build it. But
don't build before you sell. Once again,
if you're spending all your time
building something that no one's going
to buy, there's just no point. So the
second one is to start small and then
reinvest. You don't need massive email
infrastructure with thousands of
domains. You just need a few and each
domain can send about 30 messages a day
and that's enough to generate real data.
Once you close your first deal, you
reinvest that money into scaling up your
outreach. And look, the thing is people
will ignore you. People will tell you to
screw off and that's normal. Most people
quit because of that emotional weight
and how tough it is to do cold outreach.
So just understand that and don't take
it personally. Use it as data and then
if you can push through, you're already
ahead. If you guys are interested in
diving deeper specifically on cold
email, then I just did a podcast with
Sonam, who was able to generate over
half a million dollars in sales
opportunities with cold email in six
months as a beginner. So, I'll go ahead
and link that right up here. But
anyways, that is cold outreach. So,
let's talk about method number two,
which is referrals. So, why do referrals
work so well? Simple, because business
owners trust recommendations way more
than strangers. And that's not even
about business owners. That's just
people in general. Think about how many
times your friend has told you about a
great restaurant or a TV show. You're
way more likely to go check it out than
if you saw an ad or a review for it
because you trust your friend. In fact,
92% of B2B buyers trust referrals from
people that they know. And being in the
AI space, it's really good to lead on
referrals because it's very new right
now and a lot of people are thinking,
you know, I don't even know where I
could go find a vendor to help me out
with this problem. Business owners want
to know that someone that they trust has
already taken the risk and it worked out
well for them. When I first started
freelancing, I'd make it a priority to
overd deliver for the client. So maybe
that looks like adding a simple
dashboard that they didn't ask for or
creating full documentation so that they
could understand how everything works
and they can maintain it if they choose
to. Then, and only then, I knew they
were happy. Usually, after we'd been
working together for a while, I'd whip
out the golden question. Hey, do you
have any friends or know any other
business owners who might need AI
automation or might just be interested
in talking to me about this kind of
stuff? You don't need a fancy script or
a formal incentive program. Just a
simple question after you've earned the
right to ask. Happy clients want to
share. Think about how many times that
you've wanted to put on a friend to a
new restaurant, a new song, or a new
product. People typically enjoy telling
other people about things that worked
for them. So, if you've done great work,
they'll probably want to brag about it.
But the timing really matters because
obviously you can't ask for referrals
until you know that they're happy and
that they have to truly believe you did
provide them value. So typically I'd
wait about a month or two after
something's been like pushed live. And
ideally you'd want to tie that into a
moment where you can show them results.
So maybe you're doing a month one
performance review. So you would
obviously say you know like hey when we
started here are all the KPIs and the
metrics that we had documented and
here's what we were going to track and
now after 1 month of the solution being
in production we've hit all of these
KPIs and your business has grown you
know x amount. The project has been a
success. And then once they actually see
that data, you can ask about, you know,
the golden question. The conversation
then feels a lot more natural because
you've just reminded them of the value
you delivered. It's not awkward. It's
not like you're trying to sell them
again. It's earned. Now, you could
absolutely set up like a formal referral
structure if you want, but honestly, a
lot of times you don't need anything
formal. Just do great work and then ask.
Now, here are the common mistakes I see
when people are trying to get into like
the referral game. The first one is
asking too early before you've actually
proven yourself. And then the second one
is not asking at all and just leaving
that money on the table because you were
too scared to ask. According to Dale
Carnegie research, only 11% of
salespeople are actually asking for
referrals. Yet, 91% of customers said
that they'd gladly give one if they were
asked. So, make sure you are asking for
referrals. They will lead to bigger
projects. They'll lead to longerterm
clients, and there'll be way less
friction than doing cold outreach. And
once you've got clients that you're
working with for longer term, it opens
up method number three. And honestly,
this is the one that I'd be going allin
on if I was starting from zero. I call
it the Trojan horse method. The big idea
here is that instead of trying to build
trust from scratch with cold prospects
and build up all of your own authority,
you borrow someone else's. You borrow
their trust, you borrow their authority,
and you borrow their existing client
relationships. Partner source deals
close 46% faster than other deal types.
So, think about it like this. Marketing
agencies, consultants, coaches, law
firms. They already have clients who
trust them and have maybe been working
with them for years. They've already
built those relationships. And right
now, a lot of those clients are
thinking, "I need AI." And the agency
itself is probably thinking, "I need to
be able to offer AI to my clients." So
instead of competing for their
attention, you partner with people who
already have it. So here's what you
could say. Hey, I help businesses
implement AI automation. I'd love to
offer free AI discovery calls to your
clients. No cost to you, no cost to
them. You get to look like a hero
because you brought in an AI expert and
you gave them free value. And if any of
them end up wanting to work with me,
I'll give you 20% of that project
revenue. There's essentially no risk for
them. They're not paying you. You're not
asking for anything from them upfront as
far as money. You're just saying, "Let
me make you look good to your clients."
So, this works well because when the
agency owner says to their client, "Hey,
you know, I'm going to bring in this
expert to give you a free audit," you
instantly have more authority. You're
being called in like a consultant.
You're the specialist that they are
introducing. Compare that to cold
outreach when you're a complete stranger
in an inbox trying to prove yourself.
So, with the Trojan horse method, you
borrow credibility from day one, and
you're getting access into probably a
bunch of clients who already trust and
already pay and are already warm to
spending money on services. So, they're
not tire kickers. They're real
businesses with hopefully real budgets.
Now, when you are able to secure a few
yeses, just keep it simple. hop on the
discovery call, learn about their
business, understand their processes,
and tell them where AI could help them.
Now, if they hop in the call and say,
you know, like, "No, I need to use AI,
and I'm glad that we're having this
session, but I have no clue where to
even start. Tell me what I don't know."
What you want to do is help them
identify their current constraints. So,
a really good question you could ask is,
if tomorrow you've got 300 people that
wanted your services, what process would
break first in that, you know, customer
life cycle? And then they'll think about
it. They'll run it through in their
head, and then they'll say something,
and you just dive in on that process.
And here's the best part about the
Trojan horse method. Even if they don't
end up becoming a client, I think it's
still a win-win-win. You got experience
doing a discovery call. The business
owner got free insights about AI, and
the agency looked like a hero for
bringing you in. Win-winwin. And some
percentages of those calls will turn
into paid projects. Remember, it's a
numbers game. You need to do 10 times
more than you think. Finding partners is
the same process as cold outreach.
Building a lead list of agencies,
consultants, and service providers, and
niches that you want to work with reach
out with an offer that's hard to say no
to. And luckily, that's kind of what
this method is. It's an offer with like
zero downside for them unless you mess
up the discovery call big time and
that's basically the risk that they
have. But of course, the upside is
they're providing tons of extra value to
their clients and they might get 20% of
a big project. So, if you construct that
offer and you hit their inbox or their
LinkedIn DMs, most agency owners will
actually at least hear you out. So,
that's the Trojan horse method. Borrow
trust, make partners look like heroes,
get in front of warm clients without
building your own audience. So, now that
we've talked about those three methods,
let me give you a road map. But first, I
need to do one thing. I need to flip how
you're thinking about this. A lot of
people think about this backwards. They
spend weeks, maybe even months, building
out elaborate systems, perfecting every
deal, and then they try to sell it. By
that point, they've invested all this
time into something that they have no
idea anyone actually wants. There's no
market validation. So, the smarter thing
is to actually flip that order and
create an offer around something that
you know you could build. Maybe you see
other people building it, so you know
it's possible. And then start sending
outreach as if you have the thing built.
See if there's anyone interested. See if
people respond. If they do, then build
it out. But if nobody bites, then you
should pivot to something else and test
that offer again before you build it all
out. In that case, the only thing you've
lost is a little bit of time that it
took to write some of those messages.
But the lesson is stark. You can have
the most technically impressive system
in the world. But if you built it in
isolation without talking to customers
first, you just have an expensive
portfolio piece that nobody actually
wants. Cold outreach gives you direct
primary research from the market before
you commit to building anything. People
either respond or they don't. And that
signal is worth more than any amount of
guessing. So now that we covered that,
let's talk about the four-step
framework. Step one is offer first. So
pick a niche, pick a problem, do some
research, create an offer around an
outcome that you're confident you could
deliver. Now, I do think that building
simple PC's and demos is fine and
probably a good idea just in case on
that Loom video you can show them how it
works or on a call, but don't pour weeks
and weeks into building something once
again if you don't know the market wants
it. Step two is validate with volume.
So, test it with outreach. Aim to get
five clients so that you can start
getting referrals and case studies. If
you're doing manual DMs on LinkedIn or
Instagram, maybe aim for at least 100 a
day. I know it's aggressive, but that's
what it takes to get real data fast. And
if you want to take the cold email
route, then definitely just invest in
some domains. Maybe you could buy
domains that are already warmed up and
get some inboxes that you can scale up
to like 500 emails a day. Cuz keep in
mind, even if you're getting a 3% reply
rate, that's still pretty good. But
here's what separates winners from
losers. Because both winners and losers
will fail. Everyone hits roadblocks. The
difference is that winners understand
why they failed and they change
something. Losers keep throwing time and
resources into a broken system. So
monitor your data every single day.
Track your open rate, track your reply
rate, track your positive response rate.
If something's not working, then figure
out why and actually adjust it. Step
three is to deliver and then document.
So once you do land a client, your job
is to overd deliver and then track
everything. So before you start, you
have to get those baseline metrics. How
long does the process take manually?
What's the error rate? What are the
current KPIs? And then after your system
is live, you measure those same numbers
again. You show them the before, you
show them the after. And that does two
things. It first of all proves ROI so
they know it was actually a good
investment. And the second thing is that
it gives you a rockolid case study to
use for future clients. And then of
course, once you've shown them all that
data, ask for the referral. And then
step four is to scale with borrowed
authority. Now that you've got some
results under your belt, start using the
Trojan horse method. Reach out to
agencies, consultants, and service
providers. Offer to do free audits for
their clients. Make them look like the
hero. Take 20% rev share on any deals
that you close. This gets you in front
of warm leads without building your own
audience. And because you're introduced
by someone that they already trust, you
have instant credibility. So, I know we
covered a ton of information in this
video. So, what I did is I threw all of
this into a resource guide, which you
can access for completely free in my
free school community. Link for that is
down in the description. And if you want
to dive deeper into all of this kind of
stuff and connect with over 3,000
members who are building their own AI
automation businesses, then check out my
plus community. The link for that is
also down in the description. But that's
going to do it for today. So if you guys
enjoyed the video or you learned
something new, then please give it a
like. It definitely helps me out a ton.
And as always, I appreciate you guys
making it to the end of the video. I'll
see you on the next one. Thanks
everyone.